the 12-step program we all joke about
the first step admitting you have a
problem
right but it's the 12th step um that
matters
if if an alcoholic masters all 11 steps
and not the 12
it's highly likely they'll drink again
if they master the 12th step they're
much more likely to overcome the disease
the twelfth step is the commitment to
help another alcoholic right
it's service and this really is the most
powerful thing in the world which is
it's not about us it's about others you
know there's an entire section in the
bookshop called self-help
there's no section in the bookshop
called help others right
and it's not about how can i lose 10
pounds how can i find the job that i
love
how can i find the love of my life you
know
no no it's not how can i lose 10 pounds
how can i help somebody i care about
live a healthy lifestyle it's not how
can i find the job that i love
it's how can i help somebody i care
about find a lifetime of joy
in their work it's not how can i find
true love it's how can i help my friends
settle down
and live the life they want to live and
ironically
if we set out to help people solve the
problems that we struggled with
ourselves that we struggle with
ourselves
that in turn is what teaches us the
solutions